a lot of people may have missed this so
this was on a guy who I like I don't I
don't listen to all of his show but this
clip comes to us from Anthony ku Mia's
show where he had Larry King on so we'll
get this clip up at ladder with Crowder
calm but it's something that I think a
lot of people would miss and I think
it's pivotal fun dip roll the clip
the hostess gal says so we got
right-wing radio left-wing radio we got
FoxNews we got MSNBC they're both
preaching to the choir I don't think
they have any national impact I don't
think Fox News could elect a president
yeah okay did you know you may not have
did you catch what I just caught yeah
that was kind of creepy Larry King just
said I don't think forget about Fox News
I don't think a media entity can elect a
president not I don't think a media
entity should ever try to elect a
president he said it as a condemnation
because let's be honest it's Larry King
he's not a fan of Fox News saying well
Fox News could never elect a president
meaning he believes that traditional
media the era of Cronkite the era of
King that they were able to elect
presidents he believes that's the role
of media that is insane I'm amazed
nobody else is talking about this now
he's right that Fox News you know
preaches to the choir many conservatives
they do they have a conservative
audience MSNBC preaches to the choir
they have a certain audience CNN
preaches to the same choir as MSNBC but
to say I don't believe they can elect a
president and he's saying that as a cut
it should be a great thing what what a
real journalist would say is well listen
it's a good thing I don't believe that
media can elect a president that's not
our job yeah that's what they should say
but that's not what Larry King believes
he believes it's the media's duty to
appoint President
and that's why the media was so furious
with Matt Drudge when that happened the
Lewinsky scandal right what happened
with Matt Drudge is they were fit was
this was you know all the newspapers ABC
NBC CBS and Matt Drudge was taking this
Lewinsky scandal that was buried like
maybe page 9 and some paper and putting
it front page and that's what blew up
the scandal and the media again the
media who Larry King believes were able
to elect presidents saying who is this
guy putting on on page one what we put
on page six we didn't want that to get
out there because we want to elect
presidents we want to ensure the safety
of presidents who we helped elect man do
you realize that with the Monica
Lewinsky scandal for example if you were
watching dan Rather you didn't hear the
name Monica Lewinsky for several weeks
after that story had broken that's it's
hard to fathom because it seemed like it
was everywhere but I can't remember what
the timeline was right no it was online
and they were furious furious that
someone like Matt Drudge some but that's
why they they badmouth everyone now
sending with bloggers ever since Matt
Drudge and everyone of course knows
Drudge Report ever since Matt Drudge the
media has felt that it's it's it's the
duty of the media to go some some
bloggers you know Vinnie in the basement
I mean a mecklen he was just talking
about that super Mexican you know broke
some of these stories here over to the
right scoop calm or when they say some
guy on the internet right yeah that's
right that's right someone whose program
I've done several times yeah and then
after I decide I don't want to do the
programming anymore I become some guy on
the internet that was obnoxious you know
listen I mean it's it's very very key
because on the one hand you of Larry
King and Walter Cronkite who were
thought of at one point as my god actual
journalists and then the other side you
have people who seek the truth like Matt
Drudge like Andrew Breitbart now I try
and seek the truth I'm an entertainer
I'm not a journalist I've never claimed
to be a journalist but there is a line
in the sand and it's becoming more and
more clear and that's why
you have people out there who are
willing to do the job but the media
isn't going to do why why was James
O'Keefe you know why were James O'Keefe
in Hannah Giles able to go into acorn
and every single office except for one
were willing to aid in a bet underage
prostitution so you're saying I mean
they went into many and all of them were
willing to you mean to tell me that no
one in media no one on Larry King's
staff no one and Dan Rather staff
thought to go investigate this
organization people who work we knew
that it was corrupt for years everyone
who works in the political arena or the
media industry knew like hate was it not
it was ongoing joke both with
conservatives and liberals but Larry
King could not one thought let's go in
and do an investigation they're too busy
investigating you know diners where an
owner might not be Pro gay the reason is
because they believe the media can and
should elect presidents you hear that
here it seems benign he doesn't realize
what he's saying and most people don't
realize what he's saying liberals will
go yeah he's right
FoxNews can't elect presidents because
Barack Obama won twice well that's true
that's he's not incorrect in that Fox
News you know am rate doesn't have the
influence to elect presidents but that's
not the job of media of journalists it
should never be the job to elect
presidents they should think that that's
a great shame hung around their neck if
at any point people who are journalists
not opinion editors are trying to elect
presidents or affect outcome of politics
I mean is it is it just me well it's
weird because I think that Rush brought
a great amount of power during the
Contract with America era I had the big
poster that he sent out with the
Limbaugh letter back then yeah of the
contract with America and Newt was
everywhere and I think that Rush
directly influenced the entire nation
but he doesn't claim to be an unbiased
journalist yeah true Larry King does
Larry King here in this exact clip is
condemning media for not for being
bias right he's condemning us for their
preaching to the choir he so he's
condemning them for having an opinion
and then saying and I don't think they
can elect presidents so in other words
he's saying you should be bias you
should try and elect presidents just
make sure people don't catch on because
then it appears publicly that you're
preaching to the choir this is so
pivotal I mean this is a guy who I mean
obviously listen his ratings were
nothing about the time he left and then
they couldn't make Pierce Morgan work
they can't make anything work in the CNN
time slots the only guy who has stuff
there I think that is actually doing
well is is Mike Rowe with his mini you
know series because it's interesting and
and and he's a guy who people really
like and he also happens to be more
conservative it's one of those things
Lister please go to a go to ladder with
Crider calm we'll get this clip up on
the website or actually we'll probably
provide this in a videocast for you with
the clip in there so you can have it all
self encapsulated and send it to your
friends but this is what behind closed
doors every now and then you get a
glimpse right because they've been
trained through years of college and in
in media school journalism the school
where you learn journalism it doesn't
really teach you how to be unbiased
journalists it teaches you how to
present the journalism and most of those
professors teaching it are just as far
left as the people here who removed
American sniper from U of M campus so
they're teaching you how to play this
shell game of oh I'm on bias I'm on bias
here's just the news by the way we're
gonna try and elect presidents like
Larry King said he made it sound like
that's the ultimate end goal is for
media to elect presidents so whenever
someone tells you they missed it the
golden era of unbiased journalism the
era of Walter Cronkite who said you
couldn't be a journalist and not be a
liberal just know that it's all an
absolute crock everyone has an opinion
make sure yours is informed if you like
this video subscribe by clicking my face
or watching this video playing in a box
next to me also you can always subscribe
to the podcast on iTunes SoundCloud or
ladder with Crider com it's all free and
I'm sure some of you will still [ __ ]